et pour en parler justement de cette
fermeture notamment des restaurants en
suisse nous sommes avec cédric sader
gérant du restaurant le cheval blanc à
genève le bonjour monsieur cédric sonné
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france alors on vient
de le voir les autorités suisses
décident de durcir leurs restrictions
pour lutter contre locaux vides 19 les
restaurants à des cantons où le taux de
reproduction du virus est supérieur à 1
doivent donc fermé leurs portes c'est le
cas de votre établissement qui se
trouvent dans le canton du jura est ce
que vous comprenez à la décision du
gouvernement la décision je la comprends
le la décision du conseil fédéral
celle-ci gelé comprise c'est c'est que
juste un moment donné il faut leur
équipe et se fixer à nous donner des
directives un petit peu plus précise sur
une fermeture d'être un peu plus
constante aussi de manière à ce qu'on
puisse redémarrer correctement les
avaient souffert déjà deux de la
première vague au point de vue
économique
oui oui bien sûr beaucoup souffert de la
première vague
d'ailleurs on comptait sur ceux des
périodes comme maintenant qu'ils sont
des périodes fortes donc en clientèle
pour pouvoir au moins se donner aux
besoins qu'on a vu durant cette première
vague donc su donner aux pertes
financières que des mois et justement en
pleine période des fêtes de fin d'année
cette fermeture va être lourde de
conséquences quel est votre chiffre
d'affaires de combien vous risquez
justement de perdre avec cette fermeture
durant cette période là ici donc dans ma
région cessé il ya une fête qu'on
appelle la samare tu as to man 2
rencontres avaient déjà fermé durant
cette période là si je mets ça en avant
plus les souper de fin d'année qui n'ont
pas eux qui n'ont pas pu avoir lieu
j'établis j'ai pris les comptes et
ressort que j'établis sur une perte de
chiffre d'affaires de 160 mille francs
on sait que la vente à emporter reste
possible
est-ce suffisant déjà pour garder votre
trésorerie à flot durant ce mois de
fermeture
non pas du tout on fait un calcul très
simple en fait tout ce qui est cuisiné
ce qu'on vend donc en marchandises en
nourriture c'est ce qui nous permet de
pouvoir faire des stocks des stocks de
marchandises des stocks de bois sont des
stocks d'or et tout ce qui est vendu à
côté des poissons les cafés tout ça
c'est ce qui nous permet de pouvoir
payer nos charges fixes donc là on nous
a amputé de nos charges fixes et aucune
des deux ne nous parvient à l'heure
actuelle donc c'est très difficile
justement comment le gouvernement vous
accompagne utile pour affronter cette
crise on a ils ont mis bon le
gouvernement jurassien le gouvernement
jurassien a mis en place ce qu'ils
appellent des cartes vigueur on doit
demander des aides pour ça mais elles
tardent à venir on ne sait pas de quoi
elles seront composées sur quelle base
se quelques chiffres aucune idée
deuxième vague est beaucoup plus féroce
on va dire en tout cas en suisse elle
provoque à plus de dégâts est ce que
vous craignez justement que cette
restriction dure dans le temps
oui oui oui le 22 janvier je pense que
c'est juste une base ensuite de toutes
façons de faire le point
systématiquement ça risque de durer
encore durer donc on va au delà de deux
grosses failles cette fois ci l'objectif
est que mes collègues restaurateurs ils
sont très très inquiet pour l'avenir
tout cas merci beaucoup
cédric salaire pour votre témoignage je
rappelle que vous êtes le gérant du
restaurant
du cheval blanc à sean bell dans le jura